hey 42 here being a young nerd can be a
stressful life you try to drown out the
laughter in the library with the clutter
of your keyboard you polish your rare
Yoda figurine but as the years pass and
awkwardness and acne turn into acumen
and achievements you start to realize
that all the time spent coding isn't
just putting you ahead of the cool kids
it's giving you access to the strings
that control the way that modern life
works whilst they slave away in their
miserable nine-to-five but as you well
know from your annual Lord of the Rings
convention the ringing of power can be a
heavy burden to bear one which some
money's better than others so today we
look at some of the great computer
geniuses of our time and see whether
they use their impressive skills for
good or for evil so pack up your 12
sided dice put a hold on diving into
that Python versus Java reddit argument
and let's see what happens when nerds go
wild when you think of antivirus
software and I'm sure you do that all
the time you think of that little red
shield of McAfee the product still bears
the founders name even though it is now
owned by computer giant Intel the
Creator John McAfee doesn't just break
the mold of the traditional IT guy he
grinds up the mold snorts a few lines of
it and then waves a gun in its face born
in 1945 on a US Air Force Base in the UK
McAfee's family soon moved back to
Virginia where his father shot himself
when McAfee was 15 he started drinking
heavily at a very young age but he was a
talented mathematician and he got a
degree he started a PhD but was kicked
out for sleeping with students
he jumped around different jobs for many
years as they often classed with his
growing drug habit he almost lost his
mind to a psychedelic called DMT after
deciding the first one was doing nothing
he hewed up the whole bag and ended up
cowering by a dumpster from fear of the
voices in his head he even says that
he's not completely sure that he's still
not on that true
but he cleaned up and in 1986 he came
across a famous brain virus made by two
brothers in Pakistan as a test to see
how far a virus could travel this and
his general sense of paranoia pushed him
to set off his first antivirus company
he made millions through various
business ventures but was always looking
for the new thing so rather than
retiring and giving his brain and what
needed rest from the voices and streams
of code he bought up a ranch and
believed and tried to create an all
natural antibiotic I mean if he could
cure computers why not kill people too
well on that he did have to leave Belize
after being accused of turning off his
neighbor and not being able to turn him
back on again he allegedly tortured and
murdered him as retaliation to the death
of his dog none of which has ever been
proved we were like this while the only
logical thing was to run for president
in 2016 but of course the American
people were never going to elect the
crazy rich businessman who lived
entirely in his own reality Jonathan
James was such a talented hacker that he
wasn't even limited to this planet he
accessed the source code to the
International Space Station potentially
giving him control of their life-support
systems he was just 15 at the time of
the heart and at 16 his house in South
Florida was raided by NASA the
Department of Defense and the local
police he became the first juvenile to
be incarcerated for cybercrime he was
initially under house arrest what this
turned into time in a federal facility
when he broke his prohibition by using
drugs he stayed out of trouble until
2007 when police again raided his house
believing him to have been involved in a
hack on TJX a large chain of department
stores he denied being involved but
subtly he has lost all faith in the
American justice system and he shot
himself in the shower in 2008 as he
believed he would be prosecuted no
matter what our next programmer is
almost the mirror opposite of Jonathan
James rather than evading
Department of Defense she spent a long
time trying to join it as a naval
officer during World War two and rather
than dying young great hopper went on to
become one of the oldest commissioned
officers on active duty retiring just
before her 80th birthday she was one of
the first people to show that you can
program using English since many of her
so-called superior's for computers were
only capable of doing arithmetic and had
to be programmed by a machine language
and binary code she created the first
compiler which is a program that takes
source code written in English and
converts it into object codes our
computers can actually use like binary
as well as a computer pioneer she was
also a great teacher and one of her
famous props was a length of wire 11.8
inches long that she had made to
represent a perfect distance electricity
could travel in a nanosecond helping to
illustrate why signals took time to
reach satellites and why connections in
a computer needed to be very very small
she was such a Navy legend that they
even named a destroyer after her USS
hopper when which is stolen with the
Sabourin camp used to read the manual
for the IBM 709 for I can only assume he
also used its hefty weight to beat back
the neverending rut of girls who
surrounded it but back in the 60s if you
wanted to get your sticky little hands
on an actual computer you'd need a few
million dollars and a couple of rooms to
put it so it wasn't until his senior
year in high school as part of his
summer job at IBM that he actually got
to finally enter the digital world and
it was love at first sight or robber var
sight equals love but in the late 70s
and early 80s he saw that the rise of
cyber business and the free-for-all
attitude towards software that he had
enjoyed during his time at Harvard and
MIT became much more commercial and
guarded passwords started appearing
everywhere source codes were held on to
a lock down tightly rather than
published copying was prohibited he
disagreed with all of
not because he didn't think people
should make money from software but
because not being able to edit it to fit
what you need it seems like a crazy way
to limit everybody all of this led him
to set up G and you a3 software and
collaboration project that led to among
other things the operating system Linux
which IT geeks around the world will
install just so that they can look down
on you smugly and because it's logo is a
penguin
Stallman is a big supporter of heroic
whistleblowers such as the sons and
Snowden and begins all of his emails
with quote unquote to any NSA and FBI
agents reading my email please consider
whether defending the US Constitution
against all enemies foreign or domestic
requires you to follow Snowden's example
now I personally begin with hi book each
to the row so just remember that when
you're brushing away two days worth of
Oreo crumbs so you can comment LMFAO
hashtag fail on another video of a dot
ice skating thanks for watching if we go
back to the Middle Ages or even all the
way back to the Roman Empire was life
ever any better than it is right now
then you could be an extraordinarily
intelligent person possibly even genius
level